Rehabilitation like addiction doesn't
exist there is no such thing or any
record of ever having happen think
people can rehabilitate people grow up
and mature and tire of crime or they get
or they they cease to be able to run
fast enough to get away after they've
committed it but I'm not in any case in
favor of trying to change people's
characters the idea of Rehabilitation of
working on someone to make him a
different person seems to me to be
totalitarian in a free Society you
punish people for wrong acts and make it
plain to them that if they do them again
they'll be punished again and you make
it plain to other people that if they do
these wrong acts they too will be
punished that's how free Society treats
the the people in it who inevitably
transgress I the whole idea of reation
is repulsive to me and I wouldn't be in
favor of it if I believe it happen